أعتقد أنه من الآمن أن نقول إن
40 ساعة عمل أسبوعيا هو شيء
من الماضي ، والشيء الذي أجده
رائعًا هو أننا لسنا
بحاجة إلى العمل بقدر ما كان
هناك الكثير من الدراسات التي أظهرت
سيكتسب تأثير الإجهاد على الأشخاص
وزناً أكبر ، ومن المرجح أن يكونوا أكثر عرضة لخطر
الإصابة بمرض السكري أكثر عرضة لخطر الإصابة
بمرض القلب الناتج عن إدمان الكحول ، إليك ما
تحتاج إلى القيام به لمعرفة
متى تكون منتجًا حقًا ، المفتاح
هو المحاولة  واكتشف متى تكون تلك
الساعات المثمرة بالنسبة لك وحاول
القيام بأهم الأشياء الخاصة بك ، ثم
وقعت في فخ تعدد المهام على
الأرجح مثل الكثير منكم ، هذا
هو الشيء الذي لا ينجح حقًا ، فهو
يتطلب في الواقع اختلافًا في الانتباه  للانتقال
من مهمة إلى أخرى إذا كان بإمكانك
قضاء بضع دقائق فعليًا في
التفكير في المهمة المطروحة إذا كنت تعمل بشكل أكثر ذكاءً ليس
أكثر ، أعتقد أن الكثير من الأشياء
ستحدث ،
وسوف ينجزون المزيد وستكون قادرًا على إنفاق  المزيد من الوقت
لا  في الواقع ، سيساعدك ذلك
بالتأكيد على العيش حتى 100 عام